there's growing public anger in cuba
the government's being blamed for the
economic collapse and people want more
freedom
they're also calling for the current
leadership to step down
so where does this leave the communist
party in havana
this is inside story
hello welcome to the program i'm sahil
rahman food and medicine shortages
electricity blackouts
and a surge in coronavirus cases cuba's
worsening living conditions have sparked
the island nation's largest protests in
decades
many cubans say that they've had enough
of government policies and have taken to
the streets demanding the president step
down
they're also calling for more freedom
and are using slogans against the ruling
communist party
dozens of people have been arrested in a
crack down on security forces
activists are using social media to
gather support but there are now
restrictions for internet access
president miguel diaz-canel who
succeeded raul castro this year
called on his supporters to defend the
country he's blamed the turmoil on
decades-long
u.s sanctions which have dried up cash
resources
the lack of finance for governance is
due to the aggressive policy of blockade
and financial persecution by the us
it's being maintained by the government
and we have not been able to maintain
and fix the power supply plan now the
u.s administration during donald trump's
tenure imposed more than 200 new
sanctions on cuba
and president joe biden has so far left
those measures in place
he's urged the cuban government to
listen to people's grievances
folks i want to start by recognizing
remarkable protests that are taking
place in
cuba the cuban people demanding their
freedom
from an authoritarian regime and i don't
think we've seen anything
like this protest in a long long time
if quite frankly ever the united states
stands
firmly with the people of cuba as they
assert their universal rights and
we call on the government governor cuba
refrain from
violence their attempts to silence the
voice of the people of cuba
well cuba has been suffering hardship
since the collapse of its back of the
soviet union
it's now facing the gravest economic
crisis in more than 30 years
the economy shrank by 11 last year and
it's believed to be far worse now
tourism revenues a main source of income
for many cubans have dried up
the number of international travelers
fell to nearly 90
compared to the year before cubans wait
in line for hours to buy basic products
pharmacy shelves are empty
and electricity blackouts are common the
price of goods has also soared with
inflation at 500 percent and expected to
increase
further the government's reserves of
foreign currency are depleted and it
cannot afford to
buy in goods to make up for the
shortages
well let's bring in our guests joining
me via zoom from havana in cuba
is gregory biniofsky a cuba analyst and
strategic consultant from miami florida
in the united states
rosa maria paya founder of cuba decide a
pro-democracy movement
and the executive director of a
foundation for pan-american democracy
and in ottawa the canadian capital hal
kelepak author of the book
cuba military or cuba's military
1990-2005 and a professor
at the royal military college of canada
well welcome to all of my guests and
thanks for joining us on this edition of
inside story
uh mr biniowski because you're in havana
i'd just like to know i mean
anger on the streets of cuba uh many
might
not have thought they would have ever
seen the scenes that they did
um and how surprising are you about what
you've
seen certainly from sunday onwards in
fact if i'm surprised
if that is that these signs of anger and
discontent hadn't manifested
months earlier the situation in cuba has
been extremely critical
for many months now and it's if anything
surprising it's
it's the population's patience with
the the regime and uh and until last
sunday
holding back in mass protests miss pyre
in miami um let me bring you in you have
a different view perhaps and different
perspective being
across the water what surprised you
about sunday or did it surprise you at
all
no it was not it was not a surprise
actually from from the beginning of the
year till
june 30 there were more than more than
1 100 protests that we know of
so the the conditions were were
created for a for this to happen is
something is
is surprisingly that this massive
a massive way to go to the streets
didn't happen before
we were easter on sunday more than 45
between
cities and towns that were protesting we
are talking about
hundreds of thousands of humans in the
street at the same time
across the island demanding freedom
demanding
the end of the dictatorship mr clepak
in ottawa was this just uh you might say
a
a a pressure cooker just waiting to
burst
yes i have to agree with gregory
entirely i think this was not
the only surprise here is um is the
time that it took before there was an
explosion of some kind or other the
suffering that you
uh that your program is uh underscoring
is absolutely accurate
uh cubans are going through the worst
period perhaps a worse period even than
the
special period of the 1990s where
things were pretty bad but at the moment
there are other elements such as the
tightening of the
of the blockade or the embargo which
have simply
sent um the already
terribly difficult situation of the
longest economic war
in history uh through the roof indeed
we'll um pick that as the program uh
develops uh can i bring in uh
gregory again in havana i mean how
concerned were you when you started to
hear reports about the heavy-handedness
of the security forces they've the
authorities
on the island have tried to hold back
over the last six decades when it comes
to
protests like this for the moment i
wasn't
that concerned perturbed any any kind of
uh
hindrance of public protest of course is
disturbing
um i would i would also say though that
compared to
protests around the world the cuban
military has shown considerable
restraint i mean there are no
serious injuries that have been reported
by the mainstream media
definitely no deaths and i know i have
friends that were part of the protests
and they themselves said that they
weren't happy with it
but they were not allowed to protest in
a way that
again compared to protests throughout
latin america for looking at
colombia or or chile where you had 800
people
losing their eyes because of rubber
bullets cuba's reaction was
was quite restrained that does not
justify
stopping it but we i think we need to
note note the difference
miss pie i was watching you as gregory
spoke you were shaking your head in
perhaps disagreement would you like to
come in
yes of course because maybe it's because
of the disinformation maybe it's because
of the shutdown of
internet that happened from from a
sunday in the island that
they the right amount of information is
not available
but but i invite you to to check social
media
and to and to see for instance the
reports that in in santiago de cuba just
in the city of santiago have been
five persons assassinated we have a list
of at least
at least 80 names which are missing
detained and missing those 18 names are
of course
partial are the names of the principles
leaders of the opposition the principal
leaders of the cuban civil society but
these protests are
citizen-led protests and that have been
transversal in the whole island they
have been
i just saw yesterday night and an image
a video of
of a lady crying and screaming because
his nephew was
killed in the street but bitten
by the the special
bodies of the minister of interior that
the whole island actually uh spreading
violence against
the the people that is protesting
industry okay so we set the scene about
what's happened what
since sunday so let's just try and pick
exactly how we've got here
uh mr kalpak in ottawa i mean the
government's problems um
as you mentioned the embargo the
sanctions we had the global financial
crashes of
what the 1980s and the 2000s cuba seemed
to survive
through all of those six decades of you
might say turmoil plus
the soviet uh breakup and very little
domestic strife
with that why has it boiled over do you
think now
is there another reason well i think
it's just that combination of
factors that this is sustained months
and months
of problems that have not been known
before even in the special period
in many areas areas where that's not
public transport is still functioning
and by special period standards uh
electricity is still functioning
reasonably but the cues in the streets
are simply unbelievable
and the difficulties of with inflation
and and the fact that remittances are
cut so severely particularly from the
united states
but even internationally given the
economic downturn
generally and when you add to that the
uh
tremendous success of cuban medicine and
the human
health system in the early months now
overturned in recent weeks by the
explosion
of the pandemic really it is an
extraordinary combination which i think
has
meant that for perhaps the first time
there's a real
generalized loss of confidence in
whether the government
has control of the situation in terms of
being able to pull out
cuba from its current crisis uh mr
biniowski and havana you seem to be
nodding in agreement with that i mean
you're on the ground there you speak to
people all the time
how do they feel about where they are
now and who's to blame
yeah well i think that it's an
error to look at the cuban crisis
in a black and white way i think there
is a significant minority of people
in cuba who want to see regime collapse
i think there is a significant minority
of people who are blindly loyal to the
regime
and i think there is a majority of
people in the middle
who all want significant economic reform
but do not want tumultuous collapse
and i think at least the cubans that i
speak to
including cubans are not members of the
communist party and sympathetic
government
they would prefer change within the
system
because they're fearful of collapse so i
think
that what does the what do the protests
mean people are fed up but i do not
necessarily think that means
the vast majority of cubans want a
collapse a precipitous collapse of the
regime
no miss pie i saw you with a wry smile
uh listening to what
um gregory had to say because i just
wonder whether the assumption
that people don't want to leave the
island they love their cuba they love
their country but they just want a
change of leadership
and direction that would take them out
of what they've seen
as six decades of sanctions six decades
of a blockade
i mean where is the is there a happy
medium at all
well everybody is entitled to their
assumptions and their opinions but what
the people
was discriminating the streets was
freedom down with the dictatorship
i'm not inventing this i'm just
repeating
what we listened to
what we listened on sunday and even on
monday
and they just told me today that in come
away there's
there are still protests even uh
beside all the repression that have been
uh taking place in in the island the
people was
chanting homeland and life should in
spanish
patria evila the people was chanting
freedom
freedom freedom down with the
dictatorship i think that that's
that's pretty clear and i my my my call
and my suggestion for the international
community and for all those people
with good intentions and us as those
that
that constitute this panel is pleased to
listen
to the people and not so much to all the
propaganda of the regime
all the all the symbolism that the
cuban dictatorship have been able to
build
during the last decades and please
listen to the people that is just
very tired and saying enough gregory
yeah gregory is disagreeing with you but
i'll come back to you greg in a moment i
just want to go to mr pacquiao because
if you have
a disagreement and uh uh you want down
with the regime as
as uh miss power is saying many
supporters want to see in cuba
uh mr uh back what replaces it
and who replaces it and from where
well i think that's really the key
question and the government has been
able to take advantage of this for some
time
uh cubans are remarkably well educated
particularly since the revolution and
gregory is absolutely right
that there are significant portions of
the population
uh that are still very loyal not to
mention
the armed forces and the reserve forces
this is not a black and white situation
cuba rarely is human affairs
rarely are i think that what we see is
an increasing frustration
an explosion of that frustration i think
historically what is the problem every
time there is a collapse of a system
in cuba it leads to either civil war
united states intervention or both
and very very few people want to go down
that route
i speak every day with people from
across the country mostly in the
academic sphere
so perhaps a bit separated from from
some elements
but there is not a feeling in my view of
a vast majority of
uh insurrection style uh call for the
total dismantlement
of a system which has remarkable
achievements in a latin american context
and um i think that is the problem how
would you replace this what do you move
in
this general rejection of the miami
option
of going back to 1958 their general
rejection of carrying on
as one has been carrying on for the last
60 years because it's not
any longer producing the goods so i
think that is the crisis in cuban
uh people on the island in their minds
they do not wish to see
uh catastrophe and blood in the streets
but they
neither do they wish the continuation of
what they see as a government which
doesn't produce
what they needed indeed agreement and
disagreement certainly in the nodding
heads i'm getting but gregory erbinoski
let me come back to you nodding in
agreement with what mr
clepak says but obviously the u.s
themselves
um are sort of voicing their concern
and it's not necessarily that cuban
people want a u.s style of democracy
they've seen what u.s intentions can do
in other countries and it's not great
when it comes to what the world thinks
democracy should be where should the
debate begin if it's not in miami
and if it's not in cuba where should it
begin
i believe there the debate needs to take
place
first and foremost between the cuban
government the american government
philippi embargo
i think that the that the
keeping the embargo in place and the
incredible disappointment
here in cuba by people across the
political spectrum that
biden did not quickly return
to obama's policy of of engagement
uh that is the key thing lift the
embargo
first and then if cuba does not change
there is a different argument to be made
but i think the international community
is
very very clear that the embargo has no
moral basis
uh and and should be lifted and i would
like to pose
the question to miss paella does she
also think
that the u.s embargo be lifted
immediately
and unconditionally and then allow
cubans on the island
and cubans in miami through dialogue to
make changes because the remaining of
the embargo maintains a fortress
mentality and in fact
empowers hardline tendencies in the
government
and weakens reformist tendencies i would
like to know mr payat
should the embargo be lifted miss pie
the floor is yours
that's that's your opinion the people on
the street is not asking for the lifting
of the embargo it's asking for the end
of the dictatorship and there is
and the and the real conflict here is
not between
cuba and any other country the real
conflict here is between a dictatorship
that for
62 years have been repressing the given
people kidnapping
the human rights and that have put our
beautiful island into a deeper very very
deep
and and very dire crisis and the people
in the streets is saying we can
we can we we're able to save our country
but we need the end of the dictatorship
we need to freedom to do it and it's
it's actually it's it's very frustrating
to listen to
um to to foreign people that i believe
that
love the cuban people to put the
conflict in other dimensions
that is not the principal one we do not
need
any any negotiation between the
dictatorship
and any other government okay we are
able to speak for ourselves
and what we need to do that is freedom
and instead support of the free world
for that freedom that the people were
demanding industry
gregory you want to come back on that
yeah the vast majority of humans and
this has been shown
in many many polling
instances the vast majority of cubans do
not support
the us embargo again i would like miss
payat to respond what does she think but
moreover
tens of thousands let's say even
hundreds of thousands of people in the
street
is not necessarily people cuba's a
country of 12
million people so if you can get a
hundred thousand on the street
what about the rest of the population i
would say they want the embargo
listed i would say they definitely want
fundamental economic change and
eventually political change
but i think they want it done in a very
slow
cause and and secure way uh again
list the us embargo this is obviously
intervention
in a sovereignty of country and if it
wasn't why does every other country in
the world
say the embargo should be elected i've
spoken to western diplomats
who say the embargo hinders change in
cuba so if mizpah yeah and others want
changing cuba i think they should say i
think here's an opportunity for her to
say
publicly i would like the biden
administration to
immediately return to the position of
obama
and proceed by listing the embargo i
would like miss paya to say that because
i would say and i'm here in havana
the vast majority of cubans want the
embargo
listed today miss payer well the vast
majorities of cubans
on the strips were asking for freedom
for the end of the dictatorship
and a human rights defender and human
rights have been
kidnapped by the by the given
dictatorship for 62
years in my country and to keep making
this conversation
about congress of united states are not
about
the main conflict that is taking place
today today in my country which is a
conflict between
a dictatorship with a military power
cracking down
on on on armed and peaceful protests
that were
asking for freedom well i think that
that's all that what that the regime
wants
of course you just heard you you just
heard what diaz canel was saying
he was not talking about the demand for
freedom of the cuban people he was
talking about the topic that he wants to
talk
other countries doing other scenes we
are talking about
cubans and this is among cubans and
cubans
should be the protagonist
role in this in this conflict because
we are the the most affected and we are
the ones that are
asking for freedom and all that we need
is solidarity for the international
for the international community with
that very simple demand
okay mr let's go over to ottawa uh and
to
mr clippak there because obviously we
wonder with all of the
disturbances on the streets with the
international condemnation that's come
with it
how serious or how precarious is
president
miguel diaz-canel's position right now
how do you view it
well i think it's very dangerous to
start speaking in these black and white
terms
there is a crisis there is an explosion
of ire
among a large percentage of the cuban
people and frustration
among the whole of the cuban people but
to put this in black and white
terms of dictatorship against people is
really not very helpful
and doesn't reflect in any way the last
62 years
of the experience of the island as a
historian i'm
baffled by this black and whiteness what
we have
is a real problem a real issue at the
moment and we want to advance
in human rights and democratic terms how
would you
do that well you have to have dialogue
or violence and the idea that this is
going to be the people rising as one
against this government and that
therefore it's just fun to topple
it is simply not on it's not going to
work though
then mr cleb can i come in there mr
clerk can i come in there because it
seems that
uh president canal or diaz canal uh
doesn't want to have that dialogue
right now at the moment he's just
blaming america for everything that's
going on
in his island and on his island so
at what stage can there be any any
dialogue on who makes the first move you
know if if biden's
uh government in the u.s has maintained
the position from his predecessor
how does how how do you move the line to
start a negotiation
yes i think that's a very fair fair
question and of course they have done
what they always do
which is blame uniquely the united
states this is the longest economic
warfare in history between a superpower
and a tiny country there's no doubt that
the impact particularly
for access to the national credit has
been a a
crippling problem for the cuban state uh
for the last 62 years
but that doesn't mean that by simply
saying that
they're the only problem when your own
administration has been
inefficient it's been incompetent on
many levels
and while there are many many
achievements which are extraordinary in
any terms
at the same time at the moment we see
more failure than
positive things to say the least so he
has to like
he has to open himself up uh to dialogue
with a wider spectrum of the population
but as long as as gregory was saying as
long as he
uh as the embargo is in place it's
extremely difficult to see
how one can move forward because there
will be
no resources and the temptation to use
the manodura
to suppress consent descent will be very
strong
it's obviously a subject that we will
have to revisit unfortunately we have
run out of time there and i think that
we will be coming to this story
again and again i'd like to thank all of
my guests for joining me on this edition
of inside story to gregory miniofsky
rosa maria paya
and hal thanks so much and of course
thank you for watching you
of course can see this program again by
logging on to our website at
aljazeera.com and for further discussion
go to our facebook page that's
facebook.com
forward slash aj inside story you can
also join the conversation on twitter a
handle there is at
aj inside story from me sel rahman and
the inside story team thanks very much
for your time
and your company
you